find who is calling to you they may have
ounces I'm going with you honor no
excuse me I climb to the North Mountain
survived a frozen heart and saved you
from my ex-boyfriend so you know I'm
coming
it's normal
there are so many live actions coming
out now from Disney so when frozen gets
remade into live-action film do you
think you'd be cast as Anna and if not
who would you want to play onna I have
never thought about this question before
I didn't even think that they could do
it as a live-action but obviously they
can no I wouldn't be cast cuz I'm Way
too old we're way too old it's one of
the reasons we didn't do the Broadway
show I called Josh and Adina and I was
like you guys should we open the
Broadway show just for a couple months
be so fun and Adina was like do you know
how old we are and Josh was like do you
think I'm gonna be in a snowman suit so
that was a hard pass but um Wow I don't
even know I don't even know definitely
not me although I do it if they asked if
you had to pick one person and play on
it do you think I don't even I would
have to think so thoroughly about it I
have no idea big shoes to fill
well yeah it would have to be a weirdo
on as a weirdo and that's the best part
about her I love Anna
so in wreck-it Ralph we see all the
princesses Mae Whitman I just thought of
it anyway Whitman yes she can sing and
she's a mega weirdo and she's been like
my firstborn child for since she was 20
years old it'd be Mae Whitman for sure
somebody write that down I got it I'll
tweet it out with makeup and I love it
so in wreckit-ralph we get to see all
the princesses team-up has this sort of
Avengers style princess team up movie
been discussed no but you have a lot of
good ideas and I think we should discuss
this afterwards with some Disney
executives that would be unbelievable no
it has not been discussed but it will be
discussed when we conclude this
interview would you be down yes
oh my gosh of course the teams that
write these movies are incredibly
thoughtful they're they make the
experience fun because it's
collaborative like Anna was not the girl
that you see in this movie when she was
first on the page that was this infusion
of me saying can I really play the girl
that I needed to see when I was 10 years
old someone who was really goofy kind of
a
weirdo very klutzy wore her heart on her
sleeve I need to represent that girl for
me for me as a little girl and they were
like yes absolutely so there's so much
thought behind and heart behind these
movies I have no doubt that a epic
princess team-up is a great idea yes and
onna would definitely be the star of
that film I agree I feel like people
need to see themselves reflected on
screen and the way that onna was yeah
and there's so many different types of
people that's one thing I loved so much
about the first one is how different the
sisters are you can have two people that
are sort of similar and you can have
them have an argument or a disagreement
and make a storyline about that but this
storyline was about the differences and
how to overcome familial love because
Elsa is both vulnerable and shy and
really strong and powerful at the same
time and Anna is the polar opposite
she's living for everyone else she's
living out loud and how do you have a
fierce familial love with someone who's
your polar opposite right exactly well
she nails it my last question for you is
sort of a scenario okay you're
auditioning for frozen three okay and
they went to audition yeah and they want
you to rap could you give us like a ham
Hamilton style sort of frozen three no I
need to call in Manuel Miranda and have
him write at first because I improved a
fair amount in this movie but it was
only after something was on the page I
don't know how I would even do that do
what parts did you improv for this movie
the UM some of the I'm trying to think
of some of the things that made it into
this movie I've only seen it a few times
so I haven't memorized it yet but in the
first one the whole wait what is
something that I say normally out of
confusion and talking too fast and the
the the one of the main things that made
it in and was sort of the through line
was when Kristoff I mean when Hans and
Anna are in the boat and they fall in
the beginning and honest says this is
awkward you're not awkward you're
gorgeous wait what yeah that was just
something that Jen and I in the room Jen
was like just say I guess what you think
you would say and I was like I know
exactly what I'd say if a very handsome
man had fallen into a boat with me I
said say this is awkward
you're not awkward I'm awkward you're
gorgeous wait
tell me you're older and us all knowing
do you ever worry about the notion that
nothing is permanent
no you I can't wait until I'm aged like
you so I don't have to worry about
important things
Christophe finally has his own musical
number did you guys get to add to the
music at all we don't need to do much
adding to a song that's written by I
think the two greatest living composers
right now or two of the greatest living
composers right now Bobby Lopez and
Chris and anderson-lopez you know this
is my third collaboration with Bobby
second with Kristin
Book of Mormon frozen and now frozen too
and they just have a way of gifting you
these iconic songs that you know you're
just step one in a process by which
millions and millions and millions of
other people are eventually going to get
their hands and vocal chords on em hmm
that's so true right totally but his
song steals the show yes one and makes
me very angry and jealous so not true
did you put your own spin on that not at
all know that josh is so right on they
they write so intentionally and they
they also in addition to writing really
great songs right only for story so
Bobby and Kristen can write anything and
they can write they can't really write a
bad song but I think what really sets
them apart you know in a major way is
that they're really invested in the
dramatic evolution of the story and so
any song that they write is embedded in
the story and embedded in the characters
and that's all the way down to the notes
in the song with the length of the notes
in the song and that every single
specific word is incredibly well
thought-out and incredibly intentional
and it's a total privilege to be able to
sing it right not only does it push the
story forward it's also catchy
exactly is really hard to do rosin will
be made into a live-action one day
when it does do you think you'd be cast
as your characters and if not who would
you want to play your characters
I hope we're both in our 80s by the
point that it's done like hopefully and
if so probably not but who would you
want you want Brad Pitt right yeah so if
I want your accent to be if that's gonna
be a problem for me because I also want
Brad I think you should just do a role
swatching we could be on an Elsa and the
woman that would actually be really cool
but I was also thinking like could be
that Olaf and Kristoff are like a
reunion for Leo and Brad like that would
be an unexpected follow-up to Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood totally like that
would be great yeah like no one would
see a coming totally you know why
couldn't Tarantino make that his 10th oh
just tell me why he couldn't I can't
make a very I know why he could so like
I think that we've just solved the
problem yeah what do you say you're
welcome
yeah okay so my last question is more of
a scenario okay you're auditioning for
frozen three and they want you to rap a
new song would you guys Hamilton a
frozen three songs mm-hmm right now yeah
you go you go yo go Josh
Here I am Olaf Kristoff and Sven we're
walking in to arendelle again hey I'll
tell you what it's as cold as ever
except this time we got a newer flake
[Applause]
and lin-manuel Miranda are the two best
at this thing I feel like we really you
know my my Andrew Jackson rap project
hasn't yet made its uh
I can't wait some Broadway debut its
controversial but it's it's interesting
yeah and you'll see it shortly in Newark
City
how does get in the forest the mists
parted for us impossible
where did you learn magic you're coming
into an established musical did you guys
train for this what was your audition
song what was the audition process like
I've been training my whole life for the
old life honestly when I got called in
to do the auditions I had just gotten
finished doing a Disney cabaret with my
band were we saying nothing but obscure
Disney songs two weeks later I get the
call for this audition and I thought
this is couldn't be better timing I'm
primed for this and I remember walking
and going I know what to do I just I
know what to do with Disney my whole
life which one you saying well they
wanted to they wanted me to sing
something in a style of Disney but not a
Disney song I'm sure they're tired of
hearing them so I sing the Lumineers
song but like a Disney Princess okay
what song was that Angela could you do
Angela's on my favorite Lumineers
strangers in this town they raise you up
just to cut you down
Oh Angela it's a long time coming so
right need to add that to the film do it
in that style and and they clapped and
choked up and I was like I think they
were really well I don't know and then I
didn't hear anything for like a month
and then got the call and cried so what
was your exam I was not as prepared as
Evan was like this is the first time
I've had to sing for a gig right I sang
in grad school I did high school
musicals etc so I did wheels of a dream
from ragtime right yeah cuz they wanted
something sort of low or what-have-you
and I went to my wife's VOC vocal coach
and she held me sort of get the song
prepared and ready and as I went in to
sing it they're like okay so you ready
and I was like everybody's sitting
behind the booth and they're watching
behind the glass and I was like is there
any way they like you wants to close the
curtain I was like yes please could you
please close the curtain
and so they're like okay even though
there's a camera in there they could
just look in the monitor but I asked him
to close the curtain and then me and the
accompanist went at it and it turned out
okay all right obviously you know but
then again it was a month as they went
and like yeah yeah yeah so nerve
wracking well congratulations what were
your children's thoughts on you landing
these are all my kids were pretty
excited the youngest in particular
because he's got this really sweet
my oldest tries to act like he's too
cool for school but then every once in a
while I'll catch him like we were at
Pete's dragon and he was bawling his
eyes and he goes like Daddy are you
crying I said yeah man he goes I'm
crying too and so and so here everyone
to know he let sit down before the most
party tries to keep it up but the baby
he's walking around he's got his else
and honor dolls and a little carry tote
or not like totally excited for the
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah my son walks
around with the Doudna doll now but I
remember when I went for the audition I
looked him and I cuz I I used to sing
him Disney lullabies to go to sleep all
the time and so I went I said I'm gonna
audition for a Disney movie now and I'm
gonna be thinking of you and I sing this
song and he goes I hope they clap for
you and they did I sang the song they
all clapped and I came home and I went
hey guess what they they clapped he knew
he knew and then I got it and I was like
I got it cuz he you what would I do
without you you'll always have me
how's the ELSA seemed weird to you she
seems like Elsa there's this voice voice
what does that mean congratulations on
the film
Elsa has two epic songs in this movie
into the unknown and show yourself yeah
add anything of your own to these songs
and if so what of course I mean they're
written by the Lopezes and but they of
course I bring myself to whatever I
can't help but bring myself to whatever
I'm singing that's the whole point is to
sort of open up your heart and your soul
and and channel whatever it is that
feels appropriate for the character and
the role and it's a lot easier to do
when you have great songwriters and sort
of a map and a kind of like a you know
they give you the the magic carpet to
ride on but yea it's what I love about
what we do is we make ourselves
vulnerable and then kind of soar
was there anything specific in the songs
that you kind of took and just spun and
made your own probably I mean I always
like to mess with melodies but I don't
mess too much when they're written by
oscar-winning writers like blow fezzes
so normally I learn exactly what they
gave me and then once in a while if
something's coming to me I an
interpretation I might be hearing in my
head I try something where I asked him
if I can try something and sometimes
with sticks and sometimes it doesn't
did you have a different mindset now
that else is a little older while you
were singing maybe not really while I
was singing I don't know if I had a
different mindset while I was singing as
far as the age or the time passage I
think it's more yeah it's more the
emotions in the song and sort of this
idea that in the first movie Elsa was
more introverted and apologetic for her
for her her power and her magic she was
always fearful that she was going to
hurt the people that she loved and in
this movie she is more she coming into
her own and she's really embracing it
and owning it so maybe that I sang with
that kind of intention yeah
so in wreckit-ralph we get to see all
the Disney Princesses together which is
so cool but has a Disney Princess team
up movie sort of Avenger style ever been
discussed I don't know have you heard of
is there a rumor going around that would
be terrific it would be fun would you
want Elsa to be a part of it of course
for into the unknown as opposed to let
it go is into the unknown its are there
higher notes in that song it sounds like
there is I think maybe or maybe the end
of let it go is the last note in this
probably to probably are I don't know I
don't think of it that way but I do tend
to paint myself in a corner sometimes
because we record on a day where I feel
really great and I try things and you
know you're in the studio you can try
and make mistakes and and then something
great happens and we catch it and then I
be you know in London on tour and I have
a cold and then I have to sing the song
in front of thousands of people and I
say why did I put that and have it in
there really quick if frozen became a
live-action because I feel like it will
one day do you think you'd be cast as
Elsa and if not who would you want to
play Elsa oh no probably wouldn't I mean
I'm sure they'd want much younger girls
unless they use CGI but you know
Benjamin but no de-aging I have to think
of this you're the second person to ask
me this question I have to think of how
I would cast Elsa as a real person that
wasn't me and it's hard for me because
it's I always make it about me
yeah you're so much about that Associa
um I don't know I was thinking like
Jennifer Lawrence I guess but I feel
like I don't know if she's just have to
be even younger than that my favorite
actress is Rachel McAdams and down for
Lawrence and some of those guys but
they're probably too old to Hollywood
that's old and their thirties go
unicorn ice-cream castle okay
teapot Mouse Oh Elsa I don't think Olaf
should get to rearrange in this film
Kristoff gets his own musical number
lost in the woods and the entire theatre
was dying laughing when it came to life
because it looked like this 80s 90s
music video you guys break down this
scene for me too much away as part of
its the experiencing experiencing it but
I think we just love those I mean those
kind of ballads that just they were the
kind he did you know high school dances
- and you were tortured by love and
really wanting to let Kristoff open up
and so that was what inspired us and so
doing it in the vein of that and knowing
that if you go inside Christoph's head
this is what the emotion looks like it's
like an eighties music video it's just
heaven to me and and it that's the great
part of going into a fantasy you can get
it you can get in there his head and and
you know to finally see his fan come to
life in a new way it was so hilarious
were there any music videos that
inspired a particularly yeah we watched
a lot and then our story artist watched
I mean yeah that's probably watch every
single video that's out there there's no
magis too many of our favorites I loved
it it was so funny I have to ask you
guys about the Tarzan conspiracy that
Ana s that is happening okay this
question is for you and the conspiracy
is that Anna and Elsa's parents after
being shipwrecked ended up in a jungle
and giving birth to Tarzan making tarzan
Anna and Elsa's brothers what are your
thoughts amazing isn't it I came up with
that like we were doing an interview and
I naively said you know ah ha ha ha why
don't that and thinking that no one
would really pick up on it and then of
course everyone picked up on it true my
sons even said at one point they called
me is that Dad you're trending and I
didn't even know what that meant
and like no top ten of ever know so it's
not true
man but we do love all the fan theories
yeah so the more that they sort of put
our movies together the more
entertaining it is for ya is this
connected to any other Disney movie that
we know of yeah well we're funny as well
let the fans tell us because they seem
to know the cannon ten times better they
make us look smarter than we are
so I'm I can't wait to see what theories
people come up with so I wanted to ask
you about Olaf I love that he can read
now he's so much deeper this time around
and we learned so much from him but the
one thing that I took away that I really
liked was that water has memory and it's
this theme in the film so what inspired
that thought well it's actually is a
scientific fact the water has memory
glaciers obviously can hold a lot of
memories of through history and we can
learn a lot about the atmosphere and
what two places you thousands of years
ago so it's the only thing that other
materials can dissolve into it it can it
can keep what touches it it can sort of
keep some of that with it so I think all
of that well it did start with science
is that concept and then that Elsa's
powers are connected to water
Olaf is made of you know frozen water
and it just it it turned into fairy tale
from there that's what was fun
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like on behalf of the world I
just have to thank you guys for giving
us the soundtrack of our lives thank you
it's so sweet of you to say and I don't
know if a lot of people know this but in
the first film Elsa was meant to be more
of a villain and then you both wrote let
it go and they rewrote the whole story
around it did a similar situation happen
this time around for frozen - this time
around we weren't in a panic like we
were in the first one so we got to do
things the way they're supposed to be
done which is talking and talking and
talking about story everything was in
full collaboration really led by
Jennifer Lee and Chris Bock and the
questions that we knew were left
unanswered from the first one
why does Elsa have these powers what is
she meant to do with them and everything
sprang from everything we do Springs
from our collaboration with Jennifer Lee
and Chris buck including let it go by
the way we wouldn't there would be no
let it go without those two and we never
sit down to write a song that we're not
thrilled to write that's the that's the
annoying thing about us but I think it
leads to better song oh my god it leads
to the best song so we got seven new
songs in this film were there any songs
that maybe didn't make the cut or were
left out that you bow through there were
there are seven songs there was a song
first song that we wrote for Elsa really
early in the screening cycle that was
called seek the truth and it was it had
the same it was sort of the precursor to
into the unknown it was still her saying
like I want something there are
questions left for me into the unknown
is more interesting because there's been
a voice calling her and she's been
resisting it because change is hard
change is scary but there's a voice that
only she can hear and hopefully that
voice resonates with anyone who feels
like they haven't found their purpose
but their purpose is calling them
does it have higher notes than let it go
doesn't it doesn't it's this is the note
it's a flat and it's the same as the
Heine for let it go at the the voice
sings higher notes the little the
soprano voice that she's chasing but
it's the same notes but it's it feels
higher because what we're doing with
music is
into the unknown is an octave that's
your safe boundary into the unknown is
sticking your toe over the boundary and
then into the unknown is basically just
jumping out into the enchanted forest
into the place of growth and
transformation God you guys are so
magical what was it like working with
Adina on into the unknown and deciding
on that a flat always a joy because she
she brings truth to every song she sings
she can't she can't phone it in she
can't fake it she can't do what you tell
her to do she can only do what's organic
and feels natural to the character and
that's why it comes out so amazing and
those high notes don't feel phony at all
they're just they're someone calling out
and she's been a permanent partner with
us from the beginning we write to her
voice if you if we're given a
Stradivarius we're gonna write a song
for a Stradivarius and she's she's got
the super power because she's so warm
and vulnerable when she's down low and
then as she gets more as she gets higher
her voice is even more powerful it's
amazing
you